[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala nos acompaña como
siempre en nuestro estudio mar
bienvenida buena mañana de lunes vamos a
iniciar esta semana siguiendo hablando
de un tema que estábamos iniciando con
Daniela Blandón la adicción a los juegos
de azar y las apuestas ahora desde el
punto de vista de la salud todo esto por
supuesto en el marco del mundial de
Qatar Así es Raúl jugar apostar
empecemos por aquí se considera por la
Organización Mundial de la Salud un
comportamiento adictivo no que puede
llegar a convertirse en un trastorno de
juego con características parecidas al
alcohol o a las drogas de hecho durante
mucho tiempo fue el único comportamiento
Así adictivo que no comportaba el abuso
de ninguna sustancias después se le
agregó la adicción a los videojuegos
ahora están estos dos vamos a ver no
Cuáles son estos síntomas estos señales
de alarma como decíamos puede ser un
comportamiento no apostar que no luego
de necesariamente se desarrollen ningún
trastorno pero sí significa exponerse a
un riesgo Cuáles algunos de los síntomas
o señales del arma que tenemos que
empezar a tener en cuenta por ejemplo
que no apostarse a cada vez más difícil
que no apostar comporte irritación no
una intranquilidad también a mentirle a
vínculos cercanos como familiares o como
como amigos sobre el comportamiento que
se está desarrollando también que este
comportamiento adictivo del juego
comporte poner en riesgo partes
importantes de la vida como relaciones
afectivas o el trabajo por ejemplo no Y
también que haya esta necesidad de
apostar cantidades cada vez más grandes
para volver a sentir la misma emoción
estas son algunas no todas pues o sea
síntomas o señales de alarma a las que
tenemos que prestarle atención cuando
estamos expuestos a este tipo de
comportamiento a nivel psicológico Marc
que es lo que sucede con esta adicción
sí seguro que lo profundizamos A lo
mejor después con la entrevista pero
básicamente Cuando hacemos algo que
disfrutamos se activan en nuestro
cerebro unos caminos neurológicos que
liberan dopamina recordemos que eso es
una hormona que está relacionada con esa
sensación de placer o de Y aunque
todavía hay muchas incógnitas sobre el
sistema exacto de qué forma opera
particularmente con la adicción al juego
si sucede no según esta visión
tradicional del sistema de adicciones
que el cerebro se acostumbra a estas
cargas de dopamina se vuelve Digamos
como insensible y para volver a sentir
lo mismo necesitas darle más cada vez
más y así entrar como en esa espiral
además últimamente también se ha
explicado que la adicción al juego lo
que segrega esta dopamina no es solo la
El Triunfo digamos el ganar cuando ganas
una apuesta porque eso sucede
relativamente sino también sobre todo
esa sensación de espera esa anticipación
a lo que puede pasar eso también podría
estar implicado en estos circuitos con
la incertidumbre no y Qué consecuencias
sobre la salud tiene este trasnormal
pues vamos a ver los datos de un estudio
que se hizo en Nueva Zelanda hace unos
años de los primeros que se hizo en este
sentido porque pocas veces no es
recientemente que se está empezando a
bordar este problema como un problema de
salud explicaba algunas de las
consecuencias que tiene este trastorno
sobre la salud hemos seleccionado solo
algunos hay muchísimos más pero para
pues poder hacer un resumen y vemos las
diferencias el que está gris más clarito
son los jugadores recreativos luego
riesgo leve riesgo moderado y finalmente
los que se considera que tienen este
trastorno de juego vemos que empiezan
con por ejemplo Un aumento de consumo de
alcohol también no decía el estudio que
aumentaba el consumo de tabaco también
se reduce la actividad física por esta
actividad de estar apostando de jugar
luego vamos viendo no a que cada vez la
proporción entre los jugadores
recreativos y los jugadores que tienen
el trastorno se va cambiando y ahora
cada vez entramos en problemas más
relacionados con las personas que cada
vez apuestan más problemas de salud
relacionados con el estrés por ejemplo
dolores de cabeza o hipertensión aumento
de experiencia de depresión y también
negligir las necesidades médicas por
ejemplo en tomar la medicación que se
necesita o pues no ir a revisiones no ir
a revisiones médicas no todo esto vemos
que pues puede comportar un problema de
Salud Mental como son algunos de los
ejemplos que vemos aquí pero también por
ejemplo de salud cardiovascular o de
efectos colaterales de no estar
pendiente por ejemplo eso de las
revisiones de la medicación Qué se puede
hacer frente a estomar Pues en general
cada vez hay más voces que lo que piden
es una regulación no también porque es
un problema ampliamente social lo estaba
apuntando a nuestra compañera Daniela
blandona también Y por qué afecta por
ejemplo a grupos determinados de
población no por ejemplo personas de
clase baja especialmente además los
jóvenes son una población muy vulnerable
a esto y además hay un peso también
desproporcionado entre los hombres que
suele ser pues la actividad que más se
asocia Pues a este género a las mujeres
no se ven tanto o no se asocia tanto
esta actividad con las mujeres de hecho
en España y Un ejemplo muy claro en
Madrid y en otras ciudades en las que
durante la crisis económica del 2008 los
barrios más Humildes se vieron inundados
por casas de apuestas y se convirtió en
una verdadera epidemia social de salud
económica bueno como todas estas aristas
que vemos que siempre están muy
interrelaciona entre eso la población
sobre todo joven y de clases bajas no
con problemas socioeconómicos entonces
bueno esto ha movilizado además una
lucha muy amplia en contra de las casas
de apuestas en ese país y en esa ciudad
y que de hecho ha llegado hasta el
gobierno aquí vemos un tweet del
ministro de consumo de España que pues
tuvo la iniciativa de limitar la
publicidad de las casas de apuestas o de
las apuestas online por ejemplo para
proteger sobre todo la juventud y
hablaba eso de que el mundial volviendo
a lo que nos tiene hablando de esto en
España la retransmisión de la
competición no va a tener publicidad de
apuestas online y de juegos de azar como
dice él pues para proteger a la sobre
todo a la gente más joven entonces bueno
Esto es un ejemplo que ahora veremos si
si puede tener sentido o no